Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode features serious and often distressing subject matter pertaining to the sexual abuse of children and the production of child exploitation material. It will not be suitable for all listeners. The names of several witnesses have been changed.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序或我们网站上的本集节目简介。本集内容涉及严重且往往令人痛心的题材，关于儿童性虐待以及儿童剥削素材的制作。并非适合所有听众。几位证人的姓名已被更改。
Schoolgirls Alison and Mary had been best friends for years, spending most of their time together at school, soccer practice and sleepovers. The pair lived in Greenfield, a small Californian town located within Monterey County, approximately 30 miles inland from the Central Coast. With a population of just over 7,000 residents, it was a relatively close-knit, safe community where many of the townspeople knew and trusted one another. Mary lived in a modest one-story farmhouse situated on a ranch amongst Greenfield's rolling hillside.
女学生艾莉森和玛丽多年来一直是最好的朋友，她们大部分的时间都在学校、足球训练和留宿派对上度过。两人住在格林菲尔德，这是加利福尼亚州蒙特雷县内的一个小镇，位于中部海岸内陆约30英里处。这里的人口略多于7000居民，是一个相对紧密且安全的社区，许多镇民彼此相识并相互信任。玛丽住在格林菲尔德起伏丘陵中一个牧场上简朴的单层农舍里。
Her best friend Alison spent the night there often, enjoying the sprawling rural space that provided a contrast to her suburban home. Mary's father, 36-year-old Ronald Reaver, was an unemployed truck driver and former prison officer. He had plenty of spare time to supervise his four young children and their friends, joining them as they played together. Despite all the fun to be had, Alison would occasionally return home from her visits to Mary Reaver's house, moody, grumpy and overtired.
她最好的朋友艾莉森经常在那里过夜，享受着与她郊区住宅形成鲜明对比的开阔乡村空间。玛丽的父亲、36岁的罗纳德·里弗是一名失业的卡车司机兼前监狱看守。他有大量的空闲时间来照顾他的四个年幼孩子以及他们的朋友，并加入他们一起玩耍。尽管有那么多乐趣，但艾莉森偶尔从玛丽·里弗家拜访回来时，会显得情绪低落、暴躁且过度疲劳。
In one instance, her mother Cheryl asked what was wrong and warned Alison she would no longer be allowed to go to Mary's house if she continued to come home in an irritable mood. Alison simply replied, it has nothing to do with Mary. At around 4pm on April 8, 1996, Cheryl was watering the front lawn at her home when she heard the phone ring. She rushed inside to answer it, discovering Mary's mother, Leah, was on the other line. As the women's only connection to one another was through their children, Cheryl knew the call must have something to do with her daughter, 10-year-old Alison.
有一次，她的母亲谢丽尔问怎么了，并警告艾莉森，如果她继续带着易怒的情绪回家，将不再被允许去玛丽家。艾莉森只是回答说，这与玛丽无关。1996年4月8日下午4点左右，谢丽尔正在家里的前草坪浇水，听到电话铃响。她急忙跑进去接听，发现玛丽的母亲莉娅在电话的另一端。由于两个女人唯一的联系是通过他们的孩子，谢丽尔知道这个电话一定与她10岁的女儿艾莉森有关。
Leah revealed that she had some extremely difficult news to deliver regarding her husband. She explained, Ron was arrested for child molestation. On the last weekend of March 1996, Mary Reaver hosted a slumber party at her house for a group of her friends at her father's suggestion. Her best friend Alison was in attendance, as were sisters, 8-year-old Emily and 6-year-old Melissa. At the conclusion of the party, Ronald Reaver invited the girls to spend a second night. Emily and Melissa's mother declined the offer, wanting to spend some time with her children.
莉娅透露，她有一些关于她丈夫的极其艰难的消息要传达。她解释说，罗恩因猥亵儿童被捕了。1996年3月的最后一个周末，在父亲的建议下，玛丽·里弗在家里为她的一群朋友举办了一个留宿派对。她最好的朋友艾莉森出席了，8岁的艾米莉和6岁的梅利莎这对姐妹也出席了。派对结束时，罗纳德·里弗邀请女孩们再住一晚。艾米莉和梅利莎的母亲拒绝了这个提议，因为她想花一些时间陪自己的孩子。
The next day, whilst preparing for a trip to the beach, Melissa suddenly blurted out to her mother that during the sleepover, Ronald Reaver had touched her inappropriately. Melissa's admission prompted her older sister to divulge that she too had been molested by Reaver. However, her abuse extended beyond the night of the sleepover. It had been a year-long ordeal that Reaver had coerced Emily to remain silent about. Their mother was horrified. She regarded the Reavers as a nice, church-going family, and she trusted Ronald Reaver wholeheartedly,
第二天，在准备去海滩旅行时，梅利莎突然向母亲脱口而出，在留宿期间，罗纳德·里弗对她进行了不当的触摸。梅利莎的坦白促使她的姐姐也透露说，她也被里弗猥亵过。然而，她受到的虐待并不限于留宿的那晚。这是一场持续了一年的磨难，里弗曾强迫艾米莉对此保持沉默。她们的母亲感到惊恐万分。她一直认为里弗一家是一个很好、经常去教堂的家庭，并且她全心全意地信任罗纳德·里弗，
permitting him to take her daughters on various outings and leaving them alone in his care as he taught them how to play computer games. Emily told her mother, I thought Ron was my friend, but he lied. Knowing her young daughters would never make up such a serious story, she reported the allegations to the police. Ronald Reaver, who had no prior criminal record of child molestation, was placed under arrest. His wife Lea was left with the difficult task of phoning the parents of the other children
允许他带她的女儿们参加各种郊游，并在教她们玩电脑游戏时让她们单独由他照顾。艾米莉对她的母亲说：“我以为罗恩是我的朋友，但他撒谎了。”深知年幼的女儿们绝不会编造如此严重的谎言，她向警方举报了这些指控。此前没有猥亵儿童犯罪记录的罗纳德·里弗被逮捕。他的妻子莉亚不得不承担一项艰难的任务，那就是打电话给其他孩子的家长
who had attended the slumber party to inform them of her husband's actions. In the call to Alison's mother Cheryl, Lea warned, You need to talk to your daughter and see if she's been a victim. Cheryl was in shock and paused to gather her thoughts. Given the close and loving relationship she had with her daughter, she was certain Alison would have confided in her if anything untoward had happened at the sleepover. With great care, she gently questioned Alison about Ronald Reaver's behaviour. Alison crossed her arms and resolutely denied having been harmed before shutting herself
这些孩子曾参加过睡衣派对，她要将她丈夫的行为告知对方。在给艾莉森的母亲谢丽尔打电话时，莉亚警告说：“你需要跟你的女儿谈谈，看看她是否受过害。”谢丽尔震惊不已，停顿下来整理思绪。鉴于她与女儿之间亲密而充满爱意的关系，她确信如果派对上发生任何不当的事情，艾莉森一定会向她倾诉。她小心翼翼地向艾莉森盘问关于罗纳德·里弗的行为。艾莉森双臂抱胸，坚决否认自己受过伤害，随后将自己关在
away in her bedroom. This strong reaction raised Cheryl's concerns and she entered Alison's bedroom, finding the 10-year-old curled up on her bed in the fetal position. It was in that moment Cheryl knew something was seriously wrong. What followed was the most difficult 45 minutes of Cheryl's life, as Alison described her distressing ordeal at the hands of Ronald Reaver. Reaver had been grooming Alison since she was 8 years old, beginning with fleeting moments of inappropriate touching before escalating into severe acts of abuse.
卧室里。这种强烈的反应加重了谢丽尔的担忧，她走进艾莉森的卧室，发现10岁的女儿蜷缩在床上，呈现出胎儿般的姿势。就在那一刻，谢丽尔知道出了大问题。接下来是谢丽尔一生中最艰难的45分钟，艾莉森向她讲述了自己在罗纳德·里弗魔掌下遭受的痛苦经历。里弗从艾莉森8岁起就开始对其进行物色和控制（培植），从最初短暂的不当抚摸，逐渐升级为严重的虐待行为。
The next day, Cheryl and her husband escorted Alison to the police station to report their daughter's abuse. As a third survivor had now come forward, the case was escalated to the Monterey County Sheriff's Department, who began an immediate investigation, starting with interviewing all the children who attended the slumber party at the Reaver House. They soon learnt that Alison's ordeal had been vastly different to Emily and Melissa's. As she slept in her friend Mary's bedroom, Alison was awoken by Reaver, who led her into his study where another man was waiting.
第二天，谢丽尔和丈夫陪同艾莉森前往警察局，举报了他们女儿遭受虐待的事。由于现在已有第三名幸存者站出来，案件被移交给蒙特雷县警长办公室，后者立即展开调查，首先对参加里弗宅邸留宿派对的所有儿童进行了采访。他们很快得知，艾莉森所遭遇的折磨与埃米莉和梅丽莎有很大不同。当艾莉森在朋友玛丽的卧室睡觉时，被里弗唤醒，里弗将她带到书房，里面还有另一个男人在等待。
The two men proceeded to assault Alison in front of a computer, documenting the abuse with a digital camera. Detectives conducted a search of Ronald Reaver's house, where they seized his digital camera and computer from the study. The Federal Bureau of Investigation assisted the Monterey County Sheriff's Department to uncover the computer's data, discovering Reaver had amassed thousands of pornographic images of children. Online chatroom transcripts were also found of discussions held within global online communication
这两个男人在电脑前对艾莉森实施了侵害，并用数码相机记录下虐待过程。侦探对罗纳德·里弗的住宅进行了搜查，缴获了他在书房里的数码相机和电脑。联邦调查局协助蒙特雷县警长办公室恢复了电脑中的数据，发现里弗收集了数千张儿童色情图片。警方还发现了在线聊天室的记录，这些记录记录了在全球在线通信工具中进行的讨论
tool Internet Relay Chat, better known as IRC. IRC hosted thousands of chatrooms dedicated to a variety of topics, and it was here that Ronald Reaver began interacting with like-minded pedophiles. These interactions mostly occurred within two chatrooms, but members occasionally communicated directly through email. In early 1996, Reaver created a private, invitation-only chatroom titled Orchard Club, wherein members electronically distributed illicit images of children to one another under his leadership. The only way to join Orchard Club was to be recommended by an established member, with
互联网中继聊天工具，更广为人知的名称是 IRC。IRC 拥有数千个专门讨论各种主题的聊天室，正是在这里，罗纳德·里弗开始与志同道合的恋童癖者互动。这些互动大多发生在两个聊天室中，但成员有时也会通过电子邮件直接沟通。1996 年初，里弗创建了一个名为“果园俱乐部”的私密、仅限邀请加入的聊天室，在他的领导下，成员们在其中以电子方式互相传播非法的儿童色情图片。加入果园俱乐部的唯一方法是由资深成员推荐，并
the group then voting to determine whether the newcomer was allowed to join. If accepted, they would be given the password to enter Orchard Club's private chatroom. Eventually, Orchard Club grew to include 16 members who interacted with one another under usernames like Too Tough, Eldude, PoeBear, and Cessna, in an effort to distance themselves from their real-world identities. Reaver's computer was programmed to save text files of all the depraved conversations that occurred whenever he was online, allowing investigators to implicate other Orchard Club members. In an effort to lessen his eventual punishment, Ronald Reaver agreed to assist detectives
随后该群体会投票决定是否允许新人加入。如果被接受，他们将获得进入果园俱乐部（Orchard Club）私人聊天室的密码。最终，果园俱乐部发展到拥有 16 名成员，他们在网名如“Too Tough”、“Eldude”、“PoeBear”和“Cessna”的掩护下进行互动，以此来同现实世界的身份划清界限。里弗的计算机被编程为，保存他在在线时发生的所有堕落对话的文本文件，这让调查人员得以牵连果园俱乐部的其他成员。为了减轻他最终可能受到的惩罚，罗纳德·里弗同意协助侦探
in identifying the other members of his online pedophile ring. He logged into Orchard Club in the presence of law enforcement agents, giving them full covert access to the sinister group. It was unlike anything investigators had ever seen. Many members not only viewed and exchanged illicit material, but also took part in assembling and producing the content themselves. Sometimes they met in real life to film one another, carrying out their crimes. At least eight children were abused in direct connection with the club.
识别其在线恋童癖团伙的其他成员。他在执法人员的在场下登录了果园俱乐部，为他们提供了对这个邪恶团伙的全面隐蔽访问权限。这与调查人员以往见过的任何东西都不同。许多成员不仅观看和交换非法素材，还亲自参与收集和制作这些内容。有时他们在现实生活中见面，互相拍摄，实施犯罪。至少有八名儿童直接与该俱乐部受虐事件相关。
Although Orchard Club members employed usernames to hide their real identities, every computer that connected to the chat room did so via the internet. This didn't afford complete anonymity, as every time a web connection is established, a unique string of letters and numbers is formed to link a user to their online activity. This code is known as an IP address, and to details the user's internet service provider, city and state, but not their residential address or geographical location. When federal agents obtained the IP addresses from Orchard Club's 16 members, they discovered the individuals were spread across the country and even overseas.
尽管果园俱乐部的成员使用网名来隐藏真实身份，但每一个连接到聊天室的计算机都是通过互联网进行的。这并不能提供完全的匿名性，因为每当建立网络连接时，就会形成一串独特的字母和数字，将用户与其在线活动联系起来。这段代码被称为IP地址，它详细记录了用户的互联网服务提供商、城市和州，但没有住宅地址或具体地理位置。当联邦特工从果园俱乐部的 16 名成员那里获取 IP 地址时，他们发现这些人分布在全国各地甚至是海外。
They then subpoenaed the customer records from the various internet service providers listed in each user's IP address to obtain the name and address of each suspect. Ronald Reaver's accomplice during the slumber party assault of 10-year-old Allison was identified as another Californian man, 54-year-old Santa Rosa truck driver Melton Lee Myers. Myers had two previous convictions for child molestation from 1971, for which he served only 60 days in prison. During the Orchard Club investigation, it was discovered that Myers hadn't been properly registered as a sex offender, and therefore, the Santa Rosa community was not aware of
随后，他们向每个用户IP地址所列出的各个互联网服务提供商发出了传票，以获取每个嫌疑人的姓名和地址。罗纳德·里弗在 10 岁女孩艾莉森的睡衣派对侵犯案中的同伙被确认为另一名加州男子，即 54 岁的圣罗莎卡车司机梅尔顿·李·迈尔斯（Melton Lee Myers）。迈尔斯此前曾有两次猥亵儿童的定罪记录，分别在 1971 年，当时他只在监狱服刑了 60 天。在果园俱乐部的调查过程中，人们发现迈尔斯没有被恰当地登记为性犯罪者，因此圣罗莎社区并不知道
the threat he presented to children. A search of Myers' residence revealed he was in possession of approximately 20 pornographic images of children aged between 2 and 12, taken by him at or near his home. In an effort to identify those featured in the images, police placed notices in the local papers reaching out to parents whose children had contact with Myers. A videotape obtained from his home also captured footage of a meeting between himself and four American members of Orchard Club, in which the men casually spoke about their crimes. As police initiated arrests, several Orchard Club members double-crossed their collaborators
他构成了对儿童的威胁。对迈尔斯住所的搜查显示，他拥有大约 20 张儿童色情图片，年龄在 2 到 12 岁之间，由他在其住所或附近拍摄。为了识别图片中的受害者，警方在当地报纸上发布公告，寻找那些孩子曾与迈尔斯接触过的父母。从他家中缴获的一段录像带还拍下了他与果园俱乐部的四名美国成员会面的画面，视频中这些男子轻描淡写地谈论着他们的犯罪行为。随着警方开始实施逮捕，几名果园俱乐部的成员背叛了他们的同伙
by fully cooperating with authorities in exchange for leniency. Eventually, all 16 members were formally identified and arrested. Eleven were from the American states of California, Oklahoma, Washington, Kansas, Illinois, Minnesota, Michigan, Mississippi, and Texas, while the remaining three were from Canada, Finland, and Australia. Collectively, the men were found to be in possession of a total of 50,000 indecent images of children, and all were charged with conspiracy to possess and distribute child pornography. Transcripts of online conversations within Orchard Club revealed that days before the
通过与当局充分合作来换取宽大处理。最终，所有 16 名成员都被正式查明身份并逮捕。其中 11 人来自美国的加利福尼亚州、俄克拉荷马州、华盛顿州、堪萨斯州、伊利诺伊州、明尼苏达州、密歇根州、密西西比州和得克萨斯州，其余 3 人分别来自加拿大、芬兰和澳大利亚。经查明，这些男子总共持有 50,000 张不雅儿童图片，所有人都被指控串谋拥有和传播儿童色情制品。果园俱乐部内部在线对话的文字记录显示，在
slumber party held at Ronald Reaver's home, members were expressing their excitement over what they referred to as a pedo party. That weekend, Reaver and Myers live broadcast at Allison's Assault to several Orchard Club members, who were complicit in the attack by requesting certain acts be performed. Following this discovery, six of the men, including Reaver and Myers, were additionally charged with joining or abetting in the sexual exploitation of a minor. Although the internet had been used to exchange illicit content in the past, authorities declared this the first case they were aware of where the internet had been used for the real-time
在罗纳德·里弗家中举办睡衣派对的前几天，成员们对他们所谓的恋童癖派对表达了兴奋之情。那个周末，里弗和迈尔斯向几名果园俱乐部成员现场直播了对艾莉森的侵犯，这些成员通过要求实施某些行为而成为了袭击的共犯。在此次发现之后，包括里弗和迈尔斯在内的六名男子被额外指控参与或教唆对未成年人的性剥削。尽管过去曾有人使用互联网交换非法内容，但当局宣布这是他们所知道的首次利用互联网进行实时
molestation of a minor. Assistant US Attorney Tony West called it a very serious and very tragic case that illustrated how new technology could be used to exploit others. In total, five victims came forward alleging to have been abused by Ronald Reaver between 1991 and 1993. Reaver faced 18 counts for various state and federal crimes, with the possibility of life in prison. In return for a 30-year prison sentence, he agreed to plead guilty to his federal charges
虐待未成年人的案件。美国助理检察官托尼·韦斯特（Tony West）称其为一个非常严重且非常悲惨的案件，说明了新技术如何被用于剥削他人。总共有五名受害者站出来，声称在 1991 年至 1993 年间遭到罗纳德·里弗的虐待。里弗面临涉及多项州和联邦罪名的 18 项指控，可能面临终身监禁。作为换取 30 年监禁的条件，他同意对他的联邦指控认罪
of conspiracy to commit sexual exploitation of a minor, conspiracy to traffic in child pornography and sending and receiving pornographic images of children over the internet. Yet, he chose to plead not guilty for state charges relating to child molestation. Reaver's accomplice, Milton Myers, faced five counts of molestation, to which he plead guilty. Both men remained silent during court proceedings as their young survivors bravely took the stand. Allison chose to testify because she had learned not to blame herself for the abuse she endured and wanted to stand up for other children who were unable to speak for themselves.
即串谋对未成年人实施性剥削、串谋贩卖儿童色情制品以及通过互联网发送和接收儿童色情图片。然而，他选择对涉及猥亵儿童的州指控做无罪辩护。里弗的同伙米尔顿·迈尔斯（Milton Myers）面临五项猥亵指控，对此他表示认罪。两名男子在法庭审理期间保持沉默，而他们年幼的幸存者勇敢地走上了证人席。艾莉森选择作证，是因为她已经学会了不为自己遭受的虐待责怪自己，并希望站出来为那些无法为自己说话的其他儿童发声。
She appeared wise beyond her years before the court, maintaining poise as she identified herself in the explicit images taken by Reaver and Myers and shared within Orchard Club. Poignant victim impact statements revealed the true suffering the men had caused, with Allison's torment manifesting in night terrors. To support her daughter at home, Cheryl quit her job teaching, halving the family's income and leaving them overwhelmed with unpaid bills. Allison's 19-year-old brother had since fallen a semester behind in college and struggled to find the motivation to return.
她在法庭上面对超越年龄的成熟表现，在确认里弗和迈尔斯拍摄并在果园俱乐部内分享的露骨图片中的自己时保持着镇定。凄美的受害者影响陈述揭示了这些男子造成的真正痛苦，艾莉森的折磨表现为夜惊。为了在家照顾女儿，谢丽尔（Cheryl）辞去了教书的工作，使家庭收入减半，让他们陷入无力支付账单的困境中。艾莉森 19 岁的哥哥此后在大学里落后了一个学期，并且难以找到返校的动力。
Her state employee father used 1,400 hours of vacation and sick leave to attend court appearances, therapy sessions and to stay home with his daughter, inevitably requesting a transfer so the family could start fresh in another town. For his state offences, Ronald Reaver was found guilty and ordered to serve an additional 125 years in prison. Judge Robert Moody thanked the jury for, quote, Taking an unpleasant and difficult journey into a side of life I'm sure you never wanted to see.
她身为州雇员的父亲使用了 1,400 小时的休假和病假来出席法庭审理、治疗课程并留在家中陪伴女儿，最终申请调职以便全家人可以在另一个城镇重新开始。对于他的州指控罪行，罗纳德·里弗被判有罪，并被命令在监狱中额外服刑 125 年。法官罗伯特·穆迪（Robert Moody）感谢陪审团，原话是：“进行了一次令人不快且艰难的旅程，进入了一个我确信你们永远不想看到的生活侧面。”
We all know this is a journey you never wanted to make, but somebody had to do it, and you did it well. Survivors families thanked the efforts of prosecutors, saying the verdict gave them their lives back. Melton Meyers' attorney attempted to diminish his client's accountability, characterising him as an impaired person who was not completely responsible for being the person who he is. He even boldly remarked that his client could have done a lot of things that were far worse. Under California's three strikes law, offenders who had previously been convicted of two or
“我们都知道这是一段你们永远不想进行的旅程，但总得有人去做，而你们做得很好。”幸存者的家属感谢了检察官的努力，称这一判决让他们重新找回了生活。梅尔顿·迈尔斯的律师试图淡化其当事人的责任，将其描述为一个受损的人，并不完全对自己的所作所为负全部责任。他甚至大胆地评论说，他的当事人本可以做很多更糟糕的事情。根据加利福尼亚州的三振出局法，此前已被判定犯有两起或
more serious felonies faced a significant increase in their subsequent prison term. The law aimed to prevent such offenders from receiving anything lower than a life sentence. As this was Meyers' third offense, and therefore third strike, he was sentenced to over 300 years in prison. When Greenfield sisters Emily and Melissa later saw Ronald Reaver chained and shackled on television, their mother asked the young girls if they knew why he had gone to jail. They responded, yes, because we put him there. Over the following years, trials were held throughout the United States for the remaining
更多严重重罪的罪犯将在随后的刑期中面临显着的增加。该法律旨在防止此类罪犯获得低于终身监禁的判决。由于这是迈尔斯第三次犯罪，因此也是第三次触犯“三振出局法”，他被判处在监狱服刑 300 多年。后来，当格林菲尔德的姐妹艾米丽（Emily）和梅丽莎（Melissa）看到罗纳德·里弗在电视上戴着脚镣和手铐时，她们的母亲问这两个小女孩是否知道他为什么入狱。她们回答说，是的，因为是我们把他送进去的。在随后的几年里，全美各地都在为剩下的涉案人员举行审判
American members of the Orchard Club, and Allison and her family travelled across the country to testify at each. The misconception that abused children only came from dysfunctional, unattentive families infuriated her mother Cheryl, who expressed that obedient, well-loved, and cared-for children were also a target for predators. She refused to accept any apologies from the accused men, saying, they're all sorry when they're caught. These are not trading cards.
果园俱乐部的美国成员，以及艾莉森和她的家人跨越全国，在每一次听审中作证。受虐儿童只来自功能失调、疏于照顾的家庭这种误解激怒了她的母亲谢丽尔，她表示听话、备受疼爱和照顾的孩子也是掠食者的目标。她拒绝接受被告男子的任何道歉，并表示：当他们被抓住时，他们都感到抱歉。这些不是交换卡片。
These are real children. The prison sentences imposed on the remaining members of Orchard Club ranged from 12 months to several years. Some were ordered to pay restitution fees to survivors, with one member forced to pay close to $60,000 to Allison, which her family used to help cover the associated costs for counselling and medical care. During one trial, Judge Tim Leonard stated, the damage done to innocent young children is something that can't be repaired.
这些是真正的孩子。对果园俱乐部其余成员判处的刑期从12个月到几年不等。一些人被命令向幸存者支付赔偿金，其中一名成员被迫向艾莉森支付近6万美元，她的家人用这些钱来支付相关的心理咨询和医疗护理费用。在一次审判中，蒂姆·伦纳德法官表示：对无辜幼儿造成的伤害是无法修复的。
When a child is harmed, the family is harmed. Cheryl described her daughter Allison as her hero, gifting her with a pet horse to help her recover from the trauma of her ordeal and overcome her psychologically fragile state. Nevertheless, the ramifications of that March night in 1996 would continue to haunt the family forever. Cheryl stated, it's still unfathomable to me that there are pictures of my child and videos of my child that were trafficked and there's no stopping it once it's out there. They were given varying sentences for the participation and direction of that night
当一个孩子受到伤害时，家庭也受到了伤害。谢丽尔将她的女儿艾莉森描述为她的英雄，送给她一匹宠物马，帮助她从折磨的创伤中恢复过来，并克服她心理脆弱的状态。然而，1996年那个三月夜晚的后果将永远困扰着这个家庭。谢丽尔表示：我仍然无法理解，有我孩子的照片和视频被贩卖，一旦流传出去就无法阻止。他们因参与和指挥那一晚而获得了不同的判决
when she was molested online. But her sentence is a life sentence. Our child is going to deal with this as a part of her history forever. Following the arrests and convictions, the Orchard Club chat room went silent. Although their efforts to dismantle Ronald Reaver's self-made pedophile ring were a success, American investigators remained determined to apprehend those others responsible for producing the heinous content shared within. As they examined the remnants of the club, investigators noticed many of its members
当时她在网上遭到猥亵。但她的判决是无期徒刑。我们的孩子将永远把这当作她历史的一部分来面对。在逮捕和定罪之后，果园俱乐部的聊天室陷入了沉默。尽管他们瓦解罗纳德·里弗自制恋童癖团伙的努力取得了成功，但美国调查人员仍然决心抓获其他负责制作其中共享的令人发指的内容的责任人。在检查该俱乐部的残余部分时，调查人员注意到其许多成员
had also accessed another private IRC channel, which was still active. A chat room titled Wonderland. Calculated efforts had been made to prevent unwelcome to users from accidentally stumbling across this chat room. Wonderland's title began with a hash sign and featured a zero in place of the letter O. Furthermore, access was restricted by passwords and security checks. As with Orchard Club, investigators understood that the only way for them to gain entry into Wonderland was to apprehend a member who would be willing to provide them with
还访问了另一个仍然处于活动状态的私人IRC频道。一个名为“仙境”的聊天室。为了防止不速之客意外闯入该聊天室，人们采取了刻意的防范措施。“仙境”的名字以井号开头，并用零代替字母O。此外，访问受到密码和安全检查的限制。与果园俱乐部一样，调查人员明白，他们进入“仙境”的唯一方法就是抓获一名愿意向他们提供...
a key in exchange for leniency in criminal prosecution. One active Wonderland user named Sheepy had communicated frequently with convicted child molester Ronald Reaver via emails sent from a UK-based web address. US authorities notified their British counterparts, who used Sheepy's IP address to trace the user to a residential property in Hastings, a resort town on England's Sussex coast. The house sat opposite a school and was occupied by computer consultant Eam Bulldog. The determining Bulldog was Sheepy or an innocent user who accessed the same computer as the unidentified pedophile.
作为宽大处理刑事起诉的交换条件的密钥。一个名为Sheepy的活跃“仙境”用户经常通过从英国网络地址发送的电子邮件与被定罪的儿童猥亵犯罗纳德·里弗进行交流。美国当局通知了英国同行，他们利用Sheepy的IP地址将该用户追踪到英格兰苏塞克斯海岸度假小镇黑斯廷斯的一处住宅。这所房子正对着一所学校，居住着计算机顾问埃姆·布尔。确定布尔究竟是Sheepy，还是访问了与身份不明的恋童癖者相同的计算机的无辜用户。
Detectives put him under surveillance. They soon learned Bulldog rarely left the house, except to work the night shift at the Oxford University Press offices. He didn't associate with anybody else, instead spending the majority of his spare time at home alone, logging onto the internet for hours each day at the exact time Sheepy was active online. As one detective remarked, he had no other life. In October 1997, police raided Bulldog's home and seized his computers, finding what
侦探们对他进行了监视。他们很快得知布尔很少离开房子，除了去牛津大学出版社办公室上夜班。他不与任何人交往，而是把大部分空闲时间独自留在家中，每天花几个小时登录互联网，时间正好与Sheepy在网上活跃的时间吻合。正如一位侦探所说：他没有别的生活。1997年10月，警察突击搜查了布尔的家并没收了他的电脑，发现了
they described as a massive library of child pornography, consisting of 42,000 images. The enormous collection was four times larger than anything police computer forensic expert Nick Webber had ever seen before. He discovered that in the six days prior to Bulldog's arrest, the men had distributed just over 1600 images to 17 other internet users. According to Webber, it was a distribution on an absolutely massive scale. Computer forensics experts examined Bulldog's computer to gain entry to Wonderland, but extensive safeguards employed by the chatroom community prevented their access.
他们形容为包含42000张图片的庞大儿童色情资料库。这个庞大的收藏量是警察计算机取证专家尼克·韦伯以前见过的任何东西的四倍大。他发现，在布尔被捕前的六天里，这些男子向其他17名互联网用户分发了略多于1600张图片。据韦伯称，这是一次绝对大规模的分发。计算机取证专家检查了布尔的计算机以进入“仙境”，但聊天室社区采用的广泛安全防护措施阻止了他们的访问。
Although it was not unusual for online predators to use sophisticated defence tactics to prevent police from accessing illicit material, Wonderland operated on a technological level like no other. The chatroom was protected by an artificial person known as a bot who ensured strangers could not enter. There were also seven separate security checks to pass through and two electronic gatekeepers known as Alice and Sandra. A code originally developed by the Soviet Union's security agency, the KGB, encrypted
尽管在线掠食者使用复杂的防御策略来阻止警察访问非法材料并不罕见，“仙境”在技术层面上运行是无与伦比的。该聊天室受到一个被称为机器人的虚假人物的保护，该机器人确保陌生人无法进入。还有七个独立的安全性检查要通过，以及两个被称为爱丽丝和桑德拉的电子守门员。苏联安全机构克格勃最初开发的一种代码加密了
all communications within. After five months of examining Bulldog's computer, experts managed to uncover one key document associated with Wonderland, titled Basic Guidelines. The document offered tips to readers on how to evade detection and, quote, confused the hell out of the police. It also established the Rules of Wonderland Club, in which members going by the usernames I Hand, Raven One, and Jazz were referenced as being responsible for vetting new members, sometimes meeting them in real life to screen them in person before the final decision was
其中的所有通信。经过五个月对布尔计算机的检查，专家们设法发现了一份与“仙境”相关的重要文件，名为《基本指南》。该文件为读者提供了如何逃避侦查并“把警察搞糊涂”的提示。它还确立了“仙境俱乐部”的规则，其中使用用户名I Hand、Raven One和Jazz的成员被提及负责对新成员进行审查，有时在现实生活中与他们会面进行面对面筛选，然后在最终决定
put to a group vote. It was clear to investigators that these three users held a leadership position in Wonderland and exerted considerable power over others within the community. As it seemed to likely they would have greater insight into the true identities of members, it became paramount for the police to identify who I Hand, Raven One, and Jazz were in the real world. Meanwhile, in the greater Manchester town of Stockport, local mother Barbara received a shocking phone call from her nine-year-old daughter Lucy.
提交给集体投票。调查人员很清楚，这三名用户在“仙境”中占据领导地位，并对社区内的其他人施加了相当大的权力。由于他们很可能对成员的真实身份有更深入的了解，因此警方确定I Hand、Raven One和Jazz在现实世界中是谁变得至关重要。与此同时，在大曼彻斯特的斯托克波特镇，当地母亲芭芭拉接到了她九岁女儿露西打来的惊人电话。
Lucy was at the home of one of her friends and called her mother to inform her that she would not be coming home as she wanted to stay with her friend's father, Gary Salt. The 36-year-old taxi driver and former Royal Air Force engineer had befriended Lucy through his daughter and often invited the young girl over for dinner and sleepovers. Following the concerning call from her daughter, Barbara ordered Salt to bring Lucy home, threatening to call the police if he didn't comply. Salt did as he was told, and the next day, the nine-year-old told her mother the truth about what was really going on whenever she visited her friend's house.
露西在她的一个朋友家里，打电话给她的母亲通知她她不会回家，因为她想和她朋友的父亲加里·萨尔特呆在一起。这位36岁的出租车司机和前英国皇家空军工程师通过他的女儿与露西结下了友谊，并经常邀请这个年轻女孩过去吃晚饭和过夜。在接到女儿令人担忧的电话后，芭芭拉命令萨尔特把露西带回家，并威胁说如果不从就报警。萨尔特照办了，第二天，这个九岁的女孩把她每次去朋友家时真正发生的事情的真相告诉了母亲。
Over a period of several months, Gary Salt had groomed Lucy, and once he had earned her trust, he began taking indecent images of her in his bedroom. Barbara alerted Manchester Police and Gary Salt was promptly arrested, with forensic computer experts uncovering over 20,000 pornographic images of children on his computer. Salt featured in some of the imagery himself, having cowardably blurred his own face whilst leaving his victims clearly visible. Salt had also fashioned a noose that he kept on standby should he ever be caught for his crimes.
在几个月的时间里，加里·萨尔特对露西进行了诱骗，一旦他赢得了她的信任，他就开始在自己的卧室里拍摄她的不雅照片。芭芭拉报警曼彻斯特警方，加里·萨尔特随即被捕，计算机取证专家在他的计算机上发现了2万多张儿童色情图片。萨尔特自己也出现在一些图片中，他懦弱地模糊了自己的脸，同时让他的受害者清晰可见。萨尔特还制作了一个绞索，如果他的罪行被发现，他随时准备使用。
Salt's arrest turned out to be an unexpected breakthrough for British police, as his electronic trail led a deep into Wonderland's secret chat room, where he operated under the username Jazz, one of the club's three leaders in charge of vetting newcomers. Facing life in prison for his crimes, Salt agreed to grant police access to Wonderland in return for a reduced sentence. Without his assistance, the Central Intelligence Agency estimated it would have taken 400 officers 44 years to unravel the layers of encrypted information required to gain access to the entire club.
萨尔特的被捕对英国警察来说是一个意想不到的突破，因为他的电子线索将他们引向了“仙境”的秘密聊天室，他在那里以用户名Jazz的身份活动，该俱乐部负责审查新人的三位领导人之一。面临终身监禁的罪名，萨尔特同意让警方进入“仙境”以换取减刑。如果没有他的协助，中央情报局估计需要400名警官花44年时间才能解开获取整个俱乐部所需的所有加密信息层。
Salt subsequently pled guilty to multiple counts of rape, indecent assault, and gross indecency, and was sentenced to 12 years in prison. Upon entering Wonderland, it soon became evident that local police did not have the adequate knowledge or power required for an investigation of this magnitude. Two computer consultants from specialist companies were therefore recruited to work on the case full-time. It was their job to sift through Wonderland's extensive data and defeat the digital security specifically designed to keep them out.
萨尔特随后对多项强奸、猥亵侵犯和严重猥亵罪名认罪，并被判处12年监禁。进入“仙境”后，很快就变得明显的是，当地警方没有进行如此规模调查所需的足够知识或权力。因此，两名来自专业公司的计算机顾问被招募来全职参与此案。他们的工作是筛查“仙境”的大量数据，并击败专门旨在将他们挡在门外的数字安全防线。
By the time authorities uncovered Wonderland, they believed the club had been in operation for at least five years. Priding itself on containing the most dedicated and trustworthy pedophiles, Wonderland had an exorbitant entry fee of 10,000 new or original indecent images of children. Like Orchard Club, members interacted anonymously under usernames such as Satan, Guess Who, Me Again, Smirk, and Caesar. The chat room was active 24 hours a day, with dozens of users conversing back and forth whilst trading a vast library of child exploitation material.
当当局发现“仙境”时，他们认为该俱乐部已经运作了至少五年。以拥有最敬业和最值得信赖的恋童癖者而自豪，“仙境”设定了1万张新的或原创的儿童不雅图片的极其昂贵的入场费。与果园俱乐部一样，成员们以诸如撒旦、猜猜我是谁、又是我、假笑和凯撒等用户名匿名互动。该聊天室24小时全天候活跃，数十名用户在来回交谈的同时交易着大量的儿童剥削材料。
Detective Superintendent John Stewardson told BBC television program Panorama, quote, People don't realise that these images were not just children undressed romping about on a beach. These images were absolutely hideous. On some occasions, the abuse these children suffered was the worst kind of possible abuse you can imagine. The highest status Wonderland members documented their abuse of children and made that content available to others.
侦探总督察约翰·斯蒂尔德森在BBC电视节目《全景》中表示：“人们没有意识到这些images不仅仅是在海滩上嬉戏的脱衣服的孩子。这些images绝对是骇人听闻的。在某些情况下，这些儿童遭受的虐待是你所能想象到的最糟糕的虐待。”地位最高的“仙境”成员记录了他们对儿童的虐待，并将这些内容提供给其他人。
Gary Salt was one such member. He produced and liberally shared his own illicit content whilst earning additional recognition from the club for having been abused as a child himself. As investigators unraveled Salt's influence, they discovered he styled himself as Wonderland's chairman and was head of its British arm. He was also known to invite other pedophiles to his stockport home to exchange illegal images and to meet the children he abused in person. Detective Superintendent John Stewardson, quote,
加里·萨尔特就是这样一名成员。他制作并慷慨地分享了他自己的非法内容，同时因为自己小时候也曾遭受虐待而获得了俱乐部额外的认可。随着调查人员揭开萨尔特的影响力，他们发现他自称为“仙境”的主席并担任其英国分支机构的负责人。众所周知，他还邀请其他恋童癖者到他在斯托克波特的家中交换非法图片，并亲自见他虐待过的孩子。侦探总督察约翰·斯蒂尔德森，引述说，
Some of them travelled to Salt's home address and were pictured sitting on his bed with the children, not in indecent poses, but just so that they could get a buzz saying that they've met the stars of the movie. That's the sort of mentality of the people we're dealing with. In April 1998, the investigation into Wonderland was handed to organised crime experts, the British National Crime Squad. From their London headquarters, the 1500 member team launched a large-scale police inquiry named Operation Cathedral to track down Wonderland's elusive members.
他们中的一些人去了萨尔特的家，并被拍到和孩子们坐在他的床上，不是摆出不雅的姿势，而只是为了获得一种兴奋感，说他们见到了这部电影的明星。这就是我们正在处理的人的这种心态。1998年4月，对“仙境”的调查移交给有组织犯罪专家，即英国国家犯罪局。从他们在伦敦的总部出发，这支拥有1500名成员的团队启动了一项名为“大教堂行动”的大规模警察调查，以追踪“仙境”神出鬼没的成员。
Using Gary Salt's computer, they were able to covertly observe the chatroom, with computer forensics expert Nick Webber explaining to BBC television programme Panorama. We worked out a technique where we could actually watch them live on the internet, so we were sitting very quietly and watching them coming and going. They were in effect coming past us, but couldn't see us. We were able to backtrack and find out who they really were. It wasn't without risk. News of Gary Salt's arrest had reached Wonderland, and as a result, its members were acting
利用加里·萨尔特的电脑，他们能够秘密观察聊天室，计算机取证专家尼克·韦伯向BBC电视节目《全景》解释道：我们想出了一种技术，我们可以真正地在互联网上实时观看他们，所以我们非常安静地坐着看着他们来来往往。他们实际上从我们身边走过，却看不到我们。我们能够回溯并找出他们究竟是谁。这并非没有风险。加里·萨尔特被捕的消息已经传到了“仙境”，因此，其成员的行动比平时更加谨慎。
more cautiously than usual. Investigators understood, they had to tread very carefully. With Operation Cathedral underway, investigators continued to reach out to internet service providers to collect the names and addresses of customers with IP addresses linked to the club. Upon obtaining this information, detectives dispersed across the country to conduct a mass surveillance of 13 addresses where Wonderland members were suspected to operate. It was imperative they prove exactly who at each address was utilising a computer at the
调查人员明白，他们必须非常小心。随着“大教堂行动”的进行，调查人员继续与互联网服务提供商联系，以收集与该俱乐部有关的IP地址的客户姓名和地址。在获得这些信息后，侦探们分散到全国各地，对疑似“仙境”成员运营的13个地址进行大规模监视。他们必须确切证明在互联网被用于访问该网站的精确时刻，每个地址上的究竟是谁在使用计算机。
precise time the internet was being used to access the site. In some cases, the computer was situated in a share house, university or library, making the process of identifying the correct suspect far more complicated. By May 1998, Operation Cathedral was closing in on one Wonderland member who operated under the username SpankDaddy. This user's online presence was easier to monitor than others as they were constantly active within the chat room, engaging in long, depraved conversations with co-members. The user was traced to a terraced house in a backstreet of Dartford, Kent, a town 18
在某些情况下，计算机位于合租房屋、大学或图书馆中，这使得识别正确嫌疑人的过程变得更加复杂。到1998年5月，大教堂行动正在逼近一名使用用户名SpankDaddy运营的“仙境”成员。与其他成员相比，该用户的在线存在更容易监控，因为他们一直在聊天室里活跃，与共同成员进行漫长而堕落的对话。该用户被追踪到肯特郡达特福德一条后街的排屋里，达特福德是距离伦敦东南部18英里的一个城镇。
miles southeast of London. It was the home of computer technician Gavin Seegers. Detectives monitored Seegers' movements following him to Dartford's local Seekadets headquarters, a youth organisation specialising in waterborne activities, where they discovered their suspected pedophile was a volunteer youth leader who was in contact with 25 children aged between 10 and 18 years old. Investigators soon learnt that Seegers was particularly disturbed as he often expressed he had fantasies about abducting, raping, torturing and killing children.
这里是计算机技术人员加文·西格斯的家。侦探们监视着西格斯的动向，跟随他来到达特福德当地的Seekadets总部，这是一个专门从事水上活动的水上青年组织，在那里他们发现他们怀疑的恋童癖者是一名志愿者青年领袖，与25名年龄在10到18岁之间的儿童保持着联系。调查人员很快了解到，西格斯特别令人不安，因为他经常表示他有绑架、强奸、折磨和杀害儿童的幻想。
The National Crime Squad faced the dilemma. Seegers' online behaviour indicated he was a serious threat to children, but arresting him immediately would risk alerting other Wonderland members to Operation Cathedral's existence. As they considered their next step, it was decided that Seegers would be placed under strict surveillance whenever he conducted his volunteer work, ensuring he didn't leave with any children. If Seegers was ever alone with one or two miners at a time, investigators were instructed
国家犯罪局面临着两难境地。西格斯的在线行为表明他是对儿童的严重威胁，但立即逮捕他将冒着提醒其他“仙境”成员注意“大教堂行动”存在的风险。在他们考虑下一步行动时，决定只要西格斯开展志愿者工作，就对他进行严格监视，确保他不会带着任何孩子离开。如果西格斯曾经一次与一两个未成年人单独相处，调查人员接到指示
to place him under arrest. By June 1998, two months into Operation Cathedral, National Crime Squad detectives had identified over 200 unique persons from 33 nations had interacted in Wonderland, making it the largest global internet pedophile ring to date. Detective Superintendent John Stewardson explained, We could have adopted the attitude that we would deal with people in this country and we could have done it very quickly and it would have all been done and dusted sooner than it was.
将其逮捕。到1998年6月，“大教堂行动”进行两个月之际，国家犯罪局侦探已经确定了来自33个国家的200多名独特人员在“仙境”中进行了互动，使其成为迄今为止全球最大的互联网恋童癖团伙。侦探总督察约翰·斯蒂尔德森解释说：我们本可以采纳这样一种态度，即我们只处理这个国家的人，我们可以非常快地做到这一点，并且这一切都会比实际情况更快地完成并尘埃落定。
But in truth, that would not have been the way to go forward, because basically, every one of those images represented a disaster to a family somewhere. And we decided we would go forward by getting as many countries as we could on board with us, so that we could maximise our evidence. The monumental investigation posed many challenges. The sharing of sensitive criminal intelligence, network operation and investigative leads between law enforcement agencies throughout the world required meticulous planning, whilst adapting to the differing police powers, resources and knowledge of each nation.
但事实上，那并不是前进的正确方向，因为基本上，每一个这样的图片都代表着某个地方一个家庭的灾难。我们决定通过让尽可能多的国家加入我们的行列来推进，以便我们能够使我们的证据最大化。这项意义重大的调查带来了许多挑战。世界各地的执法机构之间共享敏感的刑事情报、网络行动和调查线索需要周密的计划，同时还要适应每个国家不同的警察权力、资源和知识。
Operation was relayed on a strict need-to-know basis, and detectives were instructed not to type the word Wonderland into any internet search engine, out of fear it would somehow expose their undercover activities to club members. By July, a parallel police inquiry titled Operation Cheshire Cat was established in the United States for the purpose of pursuing American Wonderland members. US Customs Computer Forensics Expert Jim Fertrell was assigned to the task of examining the mass of data handed over from British police, which included a four-page list of usernames, email addresses and possible US locations of suspects.
行动是在严格的“按需知情”原则下进行的，侦探们被指示不要在任何互联网搜索引擎中输入“仙境”一词，以免以某种方式向俱乐部成员暴露他们的卧底活动。到 7 月，美国成立了一项名为“柴郡猫行动”的平行警方调查，旨在追捕美国的“仙境”成员。美国海关计算机取证专家吉姆·费特雷尔（Jim Fertrell）被指派负责审查英国警方移交的大量数据，其中包括一份四页的用户名、电子邮件地址和嫌疑人可能所在的美国地点的名单。
As special agents tracked each suspect down, they discovered most hid their depravity behind stable marriages, long-term relationships, respected families and successful careers. One Wonderland member was a professor at the University of Connecticut, another was a retired US Air Force pilot, whilst others were law and medical students. By the end of August 1998, after months of round-the-clock online surveillance and covert real-world stakeouts, investigators had built a clearer picture of Wonderland's members and the potential danger they posed. Risk assessments were constantly performed to determine whether the need to gather evidence
随着特工们追踪每一个嫌疑人，他们发现大多数人都将自己的堕落隐藏在稳定的婚姻、长期的恋爱关系、受人尊敬的家庭和成功的职业生涯之后。其中一名“仙境”成员是康涅狄格大学的教授，另一名是退役的美国空军飞行员，还有一些是法律和医学院的学生。到 1998 年 8 月底，经过数月全天候的网络监控和隐蔽的现实世界暗中监视，调查人员对“仙境”的成员及其构成的潜在危险有了更清晰的了解。风险评估一直在进行，以确定搜集证据的必要性是否
was eclipsing the safety of children. It was agreed that undercover operations would immediately cease and suspects be apprehended if any posed a threat to a minor, but when exactly to act remained a point of contention. Meanwhile, Wonderland users were becoming suspicious, with some secretly encoding their illicit images in an effort to hide them. They had also become extremely active in providing daily updates to one another on any police investigations that might be honing in on their group. Local police agency Interpol held an urgent meeting in France, where law enforcement agencies
正在危及儿童的安全。各方一致认为，如果任何嫌疑人对未成年人构成威胁，卧底行动将立即停止并将其抓获，但究竟何时采取行动仍然是一个争论焦点。与此同时，“仙境”的用户开始产生怀疑，一些人秘密对他们的非法图片进行编码，试图将其隐藏。他们还变得极其活跃，每天互相提供任何可能正在逼近其群组的警方调查的最新进展。地方警察机构国际刑警组织在法国召开紧急会议，执法机构
from around the world convened and concluded that it was time to act. Suspects were becoming more vigilant, and to the longer they waited, degraded the risk of jeopardizing the entire operation. They decided it was time to start making large-scale arrests. In an effort to preserve evidence and prevent Wonderland members from one country warning the others, at exactly 4am Greenwich Mean Time on September 2, 1998, an estimated 1,500 police and child protection officers in 12 countries simultaneously raided the homes of over 100 suspected Wonderland members.
来自世界各地的人们聚集在一起，认为现在是采取行动的时候了。嫌疑人越来越警惕，等待的时间越长，危及整个行动的风险就越大。他们决定开始进行大规模逮捕。为了保存证据并防止“仙境”成员从一个国家向其他国家发出警告，1998 年 9 月 2 日格林威治标准时间凌晨 4 点整，12 个国家的约 1,500 名警察和儿童保护官员同时突袭了 100 多名涉嫌“仙境”成员的住所。
The Wonderland raids needed to be conducted at the exact same time across the world. Otherwise, a few seconds was all it took for club members to type a warning to the chatroom, enabling their co-conspirators the opportunity to swiftly destroy evidence of their crimes. Working together to the exact second, authorities in the United Kingdom, Australia, Austria, Belgium, Finland, France, Germany, Italy, Norway, Portugal, Sweden, and the United States kicked down doors and stormed through homes, efficiently placing over 100 suspects under arrest. While the vast majority of Wonderland's members were men, some women were also involved.
“仙境”突袭行动需要在全球范围内同时进行。否则，俱乐部成员只需要几秒钟的时间就能在聊天室输入警告信息，从而让他们的同谋有机会迅速销毁犯罪证据。英国、澳大利亚、奥地利、比利时、芬兰、法国、德国、意大利、挪威、葡萄牙、瑞典和美国的执法人员分秒必争，踹开房门，冲入家中，高效地将 100 多名嫌疑人逮捕归案。虽然“仙境”的大多数成员都是男性，但也有一些女性参与其中。
At dawn, police closed in on a small German village where Wonderland user Gronki lived a quiet life with his girlfriend. He was oblivious to the fact the police knew about his online activities, later telling BBC's Panorama. It hit me like lightning. I was suddenly dragged back into the real world. Of course, I had always been worried about it being illegal and completely immoral, but my obsession got the better of me.
黎明时分，警察包围了德国的一个小村庄，该村庄是“仙境”用户格龙基（Gronki）与女友过着平静生活的地方。他全然不知警察已经知道了他的网络活动，后来他告诉英国广播公司（BBC）的《全景》节目：“这就像闪电一样击中了。我突然被拉回了现实世界。当然，我一直担心这是非法的、完全不道德的，但我的痴迷战胜了理智。”
The last thing on my mind was arrest. I never expected to find the police on my doorstep. In the country's west, a key Wonderland member known as Ultima was taken into custody at a government guesthouse near the Riverside City of Bourne. Ultima was part of the committee that ran Wonderland, but in real life, he was a senior civil servant. It was the middle of the night in the United States when the raid commenced. One of the dozens of addresses targeted was the North Carolina flat linked to Wonderland
我脑子里最不可能想到的就是被捕。我从未料到警察会找上门来。在该国西部，一名被称为乌尔蒂马（Ultima）的关键“仙境”成员在滨河城市伯恩附近的政府招待所被拘留。乌尔蒂马是运营“仙境”的委员会成员之一，但在现实生活中，他是一名高级公务员。突袭行动开始时，美国正值半夜。被盯上的几十个地址之一是与“仙境”有关的北卡罗来纳州公寓
user Amy. In reality, Amy was 31-year-old medical student William Rosa, who lived with his unsuspecting girlfriend. By day, Rosa was studying to become a doctor at Chapel Hill College, with his training including a stint in a children's hospital unit. By night, he spent hours online secretly downloading images of child abuse, amassing a collection of 70,000 images. He operated in Wonderland under a female username, knowing that male members would trade more
用户艾米（Amy）。实际上，艾米是 31 岁的医学生威廉·罗莎（William Rosa），他和毫无戒心的女朋友住在一起。白天，罗莎在教堂山学院学习成为一名医生，他的培训包括在儿童医院实习。到了晚上，他在网上花数小时秘密下载虐待儿童的图像，积累了 70,000 张图像的收藏。他在“仙境”中以女性用户名运营，因为他知道如果男成员认为他是女性，他们会更慷慨地交易。
generously if they thought he was a woman. Over 800 miles away in St. Charles, Missouri, the trailer belonging to Wonderland member Bart was also raided. He enjoyed a high status within the club for being a content producer, with other users acknowledging him straight away whenever he appeared online. Bart turned out to be 34-year-old Scott Alamire, who lived alongside several families and worked in a nearby store. Alamire's trailer resembled a prison.
800 多英里外的密苏里州圣查尔斯，属于“仙境”成员巴特（Bart）的拖车也被突击搜查。他因作为内容创作者而在俱乐部内享有崇高的地位，每当他在网上出现时，其他用户都会立即认出他。巴特原来是 34 岁的斯科特·阿拉米尔（Scott Alamire），他与几个家庭住在一起，并在附近的商店工作。阿拉米尔的拖车就像一座监狱。
Some of the doors were four inches thick, and he had built an inner sanctum out of plywood. These found weapons and explosives, as well as a homemade video documenting his crimes. Girl's underwear was strewn about, with additional pairs found stuffed in plastic bags and hidden in the trailer's ductwork. Scott wasn't the only Alamire family member in Wonderland. His 60-year-old father, Fred Alamire, also participated in the club. At 5 a.m. in England, eight suspects were arrested and had their computers seized, with a seven-and-a-half-ton lorry required to transport all the equipment back to the National Crime
有些门有四英寸厚，他用胶合板建造了一个内殿。警方在里面发现了武器、炸药以及记录他犯罪行为的自制视频。女孩的内衣散落一地，还发现了几双塞在塑料袋里并藏在拖车通风管道里的内衣。斯科特并不是“仙境”中唯一的阿拉米尔家族成员。他 60 岁的父亲弗雷德·阿拉米尔（Fred Alamire）也参加了这个俱乐部。英国时间上午 5 点，八名嫌疑人被捕，他们的计算机被没收，需要一辆七吨半的卡车才能将所有设备运回国家犯罪
Squad headquarters. Following the bust, Detective Superintendent John Stewardson announced, "...the content would absolutely turn the stomach of any right-minded person. It is disgusting stuff. People who engage themselves in this kind of depraved activity have felt relatively secure up until now, in the knowledge that the Internet is virtually unpoliced. This coordinated action around the world has demonstrated that that is no longer the case." Before Operation Cathedral swooped on Wonderland, the largest ever seizure of online child pornography
调查局总部。突袭结束后，侦探总督察约翰·斯图尔德森（John Stewardson）宣布：“……这些内容绝对会让任何头脑正常的人感到反胃。这是令人作呕的东西。参与这种堕落活动的人此前一直感到相对安全，因为他们知道互联网实际上不受监管。世界范围内的这种协调行动表明，事实已不再如此。”在“大教堂行动”（Operation Cathedral）对“仙境”采取突袭之前，历史上查获的最大规模的网络儿童色情制品
was 7,000 separate images. After examining over 100 Wonderland members' computers, police uncovered a staggering 750,000 images of child abuse, along with 1,800 video clips featuring some of the most degrading footage they had ever witnessed. One Italian man owned 180,000 images alone. As some of the computer hardware was so highly protected and impossible to decode, experts estimated the true number of illicit images amassed by the group might have been upwards of 2 million.
是 7,000 张独立图像。在检查了 100 多名“仙境”成员的计算机后，警方发现了惊人的 750,000 张虐待儿童图像，以及 1,800 个视频剪辑，其中包含他们见过的最令人发指的画面。仅一名意大利男子就拥有 180,000 张图片。由于一些计算机硬件受到高度保护且无法解码，专家估计该组织积累的非法图片的真实数字可能高达 200 万张。
Officers given the difficult task of viewing the material broke down in tears. Detective Chief Inspector Alex Wood told BBC's Panorama, "...certainly one series that sticks in my mind is a series that was labelled Colby. Colby would appear to be a child of no more than a year old, and the initial images are of a young toddler, very blonde hair to lad, walking in a hallway in nappies. That image goes through some 20 or 30 slides and ends up with the most horrific abuse of a child. Certainly, like the rest of the team, I guess that one image probably stays with you, and
被委以观看这些材料这一艰巨任务的警官们当场痛哭流涕。侦探总督察亚历克斯·伍德（Alex Wood）告诉英国广播公司（BBC）的《全景》节目：“……有一个系列确实深深印在我的脑海里，那就是被标为‘科尔比’（Colby）的系列。科尔比似乎是一个一岁左右的孩子，最初的图像是一个穿着尿布、金发的小男孩在走廊里走路。该图像经过大约 20 到 30 张幻灯片，最终演变成对儿童最可怕的虐待。当然，就像团队其他人一样，我想那个图像可能会伴随你一生，
that for me would be the most horrible that I saw." Some of the encryption used by Wonderland members was so advanced that even the world's leading code-breaking experts were unable to crack it. The computer of 40-year-old UK-based computer salesman Stephen Ellis was sent to government intelligence agencies in the United States, where experts ran code-breaking programs on his system for a month with no success. Ellis had ended his own life just days after his first court appearance for his involvement with Wonderland.
对我来说，那是我看过的最可怕的。”“仙境”成员使用的一些加密技术非常先进，以至于连世界领先的密码破译专家也无法破解。40 岁的英国计算机销售员斯蒂芬·埃利斯（Stephen Ellis）的计算机被送到美国的政府情报机构，那里的专家在他的系统上运行了一个月的密码破译程序，但没有成功。埃利斯在因参与“仙境”而首次出庭几天后自杀身亡。
If he was still alive, he would never have faced trial, as investigators were unable to obtain the evidence required to use against him. Stephen Ellis was one of seven Wonderland members who took their lives following their arrest. It took years for authorities to intercept, preserve, analyze, and prepare all available evidence before taking Wonderland members to trial, many of whom were granted bail throughout this process. After a two-year effort, in February 2001, the seven remaining UK-based members pleaded
如果他还活着，他将永远不会面临审判，因为调查人员无法获得对付他所需的证据。斯蒂芬·埃利斯是因被捕而自杀的七名“仙境”成员之一。当局花了数年时间拦截、保存、分析和准备所有可用证据，然后才将“仙境”成员送上法庭，其中许多人在整个过程中获得了保释。经过两年的努力，2001 年 2 月，剩下的七名英国成员承认
guilty to conspiracy to distribute indecent images of children. He accused were mostly computer consultants, technicians, and taxi drivers. At the forefront was 31-year-old Ian Baldock, whose association with convicted awkward club child Milester Ronald Reaver led to the complete downfall of Wonderland, along with his closest cohort, 29-year-old youth volunteer Gavin Seegers, regarded as one of the club's more dangerous members. 30-year-old unemployed man David Hine spoke publicly about his involvement in Wonderland, telling BBC's Panorama that he had found child pornography online within 24 hours of gaining
串谋传播儿童淫秽图像。被告大多是计算机顾问、技术人员和出租车司机。走在最前面的是 31 岁的伊恩·鲍多克（Ian Baldock），他与已被定罪的俱乐部成员迈尔斯特·罗纳德·里弗（Milester Ronald Reaver）的交往导致了“仙境”的彻底垮台，此外还有他最亲密的同伙、29 岁的青年志愿者加文·西格斯（Gavin Seegers），他被认为是该俱乐部较危险的成员之一。30 岁的失业男子大卫·海恩（David Hine）公开谈论了他参与“仙境”的经历，他告诉英国广播公司（BBC）的《全景》节目，他在获得
access to the internet. He showed no remorse for his crimes, saying it was great to find a like-minded people who shared his interest in pedophilia. He explained, quote, We didn't see it as abuse. We just saw it as some members being in relationships with children. The net draws you in. It sucks you in.
互联网访问权限后 24 小时内在网上找到了儿童色情制品。他对自己的罪行毫无悔意，并表示很高兴能找到志同道合、对恋童癖有共同兴趣的人。他解释说，引述：“我们不认为这是一种虐待。我们只认为这只是一些成员与儿童建立了关系。网络把你拉了进去。它把你吸了进去。”
I had people I could talk to. I had people I could trade images with. I never had so many friends before. 46-year-old Frederick Stevens had only been involved in Wonderland for six months, but had already amassed close to 9,000 images and over 600 videos within that short timeframe. Despite having a young family, he made no effort to protect the obscene content on his computer with a password or encryption. In contrast, 25-year-old Andrew Barlow had configured his computer in such a highly
我有可以交谈的人。我有可以与之交换图片的人。我以前从来没有过这么多朋友。46 岁的弗雷德里克·史蒂芬斯（Frederick Stevens）参与“仙境”只有六个月，但在这么短的时间内，他已经积累了近 9,000 张图片和 600 多个视频。尽管有一个年轻的家庭，但他没有费心使用密码或加密来保护计算机上的淫秽内容。相比之下，25 岁的安德ルー·巴洛（Andrew Barlow）将他的计算机配置得高度
secretive manner that authorities were only able to retrieve 200 obscene images from what they believed to be a much larger collection. 31-year-old Ahmed Ali maintained that 90% of the 13,000 pornographic images of children found on his computer were, quote, Friendly, harmless stuff. 36-year-old Anthony Skinner was one of the offenders who visited Gary Salt's Stockport Home to meet the children Salt abused in his videos. Skinner emailed photos of his encounters to Wonderland members as a twisted memento.
隐秘，以至于当局只能从他们认为规模大得多的收藏中检索到 200 张淫秽图片。31 岁的艾哈迈德·阿里（Ahmed Ali）坚称，在他的计算机上发现的 13,000 张儿童色情图片中，有 90% 是引述：“友好、无害的东西。” 36 岁的安东尼·斯金纳（Anthony Skinner）是造访加里·萨特（Gary Salt）斯托克波特家中的违法者之一，目的是见萨特在其视频中虐待的儿童。斯金纳将他相遇的照片通过电子邮件发送给“仙境”成员作为扭曲的纪念品。
In defense of his actions, Skinner's lawyer stated, The internet sucks you in and becomes an obsession. It becomes your life. It is a dichotomy of repulsion and attraction, fantasy, and reality. On February 13, 2001, the seven guilty men appeared together at Kingston-upon-Tems Crown Court to receive their sentencing. Prosecutor David Perry detailed the defendant's secret and secure digital underworld, telling the court.
为了辩护自己的行为，斯金纳的律师表示：“互联网把你吸了进去，成了一种痴迷。它成了你的生活。这是排斥与吸引、幻想与现实的二分法。” 2001 年 2 月 13 日，这七名有罪的男子一同出现在泰晤士河畔金斯顿刑事法庭接受宣判。检察官大卫·佩里（David Perry）详细阐述了被告秘密且安全的数字地下世界，并对法庭进行了陈述。
Each of them was involved in the distribution of indecent material on the internet throughout the world. The indecent material depicted children involved in sexual acts with adults and also with other children. All of the children involved were under the age of 16, and in one case, the child was only three months. Each defendant had a huge quantity of indecent images stored in the hard drives of their computers and on compact discs.
他们每人都参与了在世界各地互联网上分发淫秽材料的活动。这些淫秽材料描绘了儿童与成人以及其他儿童进行性行为的场景。所有涉案儿童均在 16 岁以下，在一个案例中，儿童年仅三个月。每个被告的计算机硬盘和光盘上都存储了大量淫秽图像。
There was a vast international lending library whose members swapped a vast quantity of pedophile images. Judge Kenneth McCrae addressed the defendants who stood passively in the dark, telling them, You directly or indirectly exploited the most vulnerable in our society. Children represent the future they should be cared for and protected. You have betrayed that principle. The use and abuse of children for your own gratification has horrified me. You have used your computer skills to do this.
有一个庞大的国际出借图书馆，其成员交换了大量的恋童癖图像。法官肯尼斯·麦克雷（Kenneth McCrae）向站在黑暗中神情被动的被告发表讲话，对他们说：“你们直接或间接地剥削了我们社会中最脆弱的人。儿童代表着未来，他们应该受到关怀和保护。你们背叛了这一原则。为了你们自己的满足而使用和虐待儿童令我感到震惊。你们利用你们的计算机技能来做到这一点。”
The photographic records are proof of your perversity. According to their counsel, the defendants were suffering from a classic pattern of pedophilia where abuse was perceived as affection and had simply paned to their basic sexual interests. Judge McCrae deemed these claims to be nonsense and was equally critical of Anthony Skinner's assertion that he was only recruited into the ring for his encryption skills, telling him that he was like so many others, still in denial. Under British law at the time, the maximum sentence that could be imposed for such offences was just three years, but Judge McCrae had to give credit to the offenders for pleading
这些摄影记录就是你们变态的证据。据他们的辩护律师称，被告正遭受着恋童癖的典型模式的折磨，即虐待被视为爱意，他们只是迎合了他们基本的性趣。麦克雷法官认为这些说法纯属无稽之谈，并同样批评了安东尼·斯金纳关于他仅仅因为加密技能而被招募入该团伙的断言，告诉他他就像许多其他人一样，仍然在否认现实。根据当时英国法律，此类犯罪可判处的最高刑期仅为三年，但麦克雷法官不得不承认罪犯认罪的态度
guilty. As such, for their participation in the world's largest known online pedophile ring, the defendants were handed prison sentences ranging from 12 to 30 months. They were ordered to serve at least half their allotted term and remain on license for the remainder, which meant they would be released back into the community under certain conditions, including the forfeiture of their computer equipment. Five of the men were placed on the sex offender's registry for seven years, while Liam Baldock and David Hines were the only two placed on the registry for life.
有罪。因此，由于参与了全球最大的已知在线恋童癖网络，被告被判处12至30个月不等的监禁。他们被勒令服刑至少一半，其余刑期保持缓刑，这意味着他们将在特定条件下被释放回社区，包括没收其计算机设备。其中五名男子被列入性犯罪者登记册七年，而利亚姆·鲍尔多克和大卫·海恩斯是仅有的两名被终身列入登记册的人。
The Wonderland trial was viewed by many as a test case for dealing with pedophile activity on the internet, and the controversial penalties handed to the perpetrators were immediately condemned. Whilst the sentences were as severe as investigators for Operation Cathedral expected, a coalition of seven UK charities campaigning for child protection said they were deeply disappointed by the results. While praising the efforts of police in tackling internet crime and child sex abuse, they worried the lenient sentences meant that pedophiles would continue to thrive online.
“仙境”案的审判被许多人视为处理互联网上恋童癖活动的试金石，对肇事者充满争议的判罚立即受到了谴责。虽然这些判决与“大教堂行动”调查人员预期的严厉程度相当，但一个由七家英国儿童保护慈善机构组成的联盟表示对结果深感失望。在赞扬警方打击互联网犯罪和儿童性虐待的努力的同时，他们担心宽大处理意味着恋童癖者将继续在网上滋生。
Ruth Dixon, the deputy chief executive of the Internet Watch Foundation, told BBC News journalists that the internet must not be seen as a safe, anonymous haven for people to do what they like. Director of the Child Protection Charity Kidscape, Dr Michelle Elliott, called the sentences a joke, saying, You would get a longer sentence for accumulating masses of parking tickets or for burglary. I am absolutely stupefied by this leniency. That sends a clear message that these crimes are not being taken seriously.
互联网观察基金会副首席执行官露丝·迪克森告诉BBC新闻记者，互联网绝不能被视为人们随心所欲的安全匿名避难所。儿童保护慈善机构Kidscape的主任米歇尔·埃利奥特博士称这些判决是个笑话，她说：“积累大量的停车罚单或入室盗窃会得到更重的判决。我对这种宽大处理感到绝对震惊。这传达了一个明确的信息，即这些罪行没有受到严肃对待。”
The courts should be concentrating on the pitches these men collected of horrific child abuse which encourages more abuse of vulnerable children. If we want to stop people doing things like this, 12 months is no deterrent, especially when they will be out in half the time. London-based attorney Robin Bynow believed plea bargaining was inappropriate in such a case, explaining, Whether it is a lightest sentence or not, they are effectively getting cash back for not wasting the court's time.
法院应集中精力处理这些人收集的令人发指的虐待儿童照片，这些照片鼓励了对弱如果我们想阻止人们做这种事，12个月的震慑力微乎其微，尤其是当他们一半时间就能出来的时候。伦敦律师罗宾·拜诺认为认罪协商在这种案件中是不合适的，他解释说：“不管是不是最轻的判决，他们实际上是通过不浪费法院时间来换取利益。”
I think where there is a case like this, where material of this nature is being disseminated, it sends out the wrong message if nobody gets the maximum sentence. The judicial system owes it to the nation when something is being dealt with for the first time, as is the case here, that all the issues are considered in a full-strength trial. Nevertheless, for the officer in charge of Operation Cathedral, Detective Superintendent Peter Spindler, the convictions were a victory. When the crime squad took on the operation, we were aware that they could only be sentenced
我认为在这样一桩传播这种性质材料的案件中，如果没有人被判处最高刑罚，就会发出错误的信号。当某件事情是第一次处理时，司法系统亏欠国家一个全面彻底的审判，就像这里的情况一样，所有的问都应该经过全力审判来考虑。然而，对于“大教堂行动”的负责人、侦缉警司彼得·施因德勒来说，定罪是一场胜利。当犯罪调查组接手该行动时，我们意识到他们只能被判处
to three years in prison, but we had to take on the operation to highlight the level of appalling behaviour on the internet. It has contributed to change. It's a great relief to conclude what's been a very long operation. We can combat crime on the internet. We won't tolerate child pornography in the UK. If anybody thinks that in a modern, civilised society that a sexual preference for children is acceptable, then they're wrong.
三年监禁，但我们必须开展这项行动，以揭示互联网上令人发指的行为水平。这有助于改变现状。结束这场历时很长的行动是一个巨大的安慰。我们可以打击互联网上的犯罪。我们在英国不容忍儿童色情。如果任何人认为在现代文明社会中，对儿童的性偏好是可以接受的，那么他们就错了。
And the prison sentences in the future will be three times as long as they've been today. As the Operation Cathedral arrests were underway, a new law was proposed in the UK to increase the maximum sentence for such offences to ten years. It was passed by British Parliament in January 2001, and although this was too late to impact the Wonderland trials, it ensured pedophiles appearing in court in the future would face far more severe sentencing. As a result of the inquiry, harsher legislation was also introduced overseas. Following the breakdown of the Wonderland network, officers who took part in Operation
未来的刑期将是今天的三倍。在“大教堂行动”逮捕行动进行的同时，英国提出了一项新法案，将此类犯罪的最高刑期提高到十年。它于2001年1月由英国议会通过，尽管这对于影响“仙境”案审判来说为时已晚，但它确保了未来出庭的恋童癖者将面临更严厉的判决。作为调查的结果，海外也引入了更严厉的立法。在“仙境”网络崩溃之后，参与行动的警官们因其勤勉以及观看所有非法材料这一吃力不讨好的任务而受到表扬
Cathedral were praised for their diligence and the thankless task of viewing all the illicit material. The investigation had a profound impact on those involved, with officers having to undergo compulsory psychological debriefing and some retiring from the force altogether. The Deputy Director-General of the National Crime Squad, Bob Packham, stated, It has been a difficult and distressing investigation, and I hope that our actions have prevented further abuse of children across the world. The National Directors of Charity Organisations Save the Children and End Child Prostitution
“大教堂行动”的警员们因其勤勉以及观看所有非法材料这一吃力不讨好的任务而受到表扬。这次调查对涉案人员产生了深远的影响，警官们不得不接受强制性的心理汇报，甚至有人完全退出了警队。国家犯罪调查局副局长鲍勃·帕克姆表示：“这是一次困难且令人痛苦的调查，我希望我们的行动能够防止全球范围内对儿童的进一步虐待。”慈善机构“救助儿童会”和“终结儿童卖淫”的国家总监
Pornography and Trafficking released a joint statement that read, We applaud the raid on the internet child pornography ring known as Wonderland. The raid is a timely reminder of the need for a coordinated approach to fight this threat to children, but also a message of hope for the results that cooperation can bring. With 40 million internet users worldwide, the threat is a truly global one. Child sex offenders who formerly met to swap child pornography in secret can now do so from any country in the world, in the apparent security of their own homes. The ease of spreading such images also threatens to introduce new and wider audiences, a fact
色情和贩运发布了一起联合声明，其中写道：“我们赞赏对被称为‘仙境’的互联网儿童色情团伙的突击搜查。这次突击搜查及时提醒我们需要采取协调一致的方法来打击对儿童的这一威胁，同时也为合作带来的成果传递了希望的信息。全球有4万亿互联网用户，这种威胁真正是全球性的。以前秘密交换儿童色情制品的儿童性罪犯现在可以在世界上的任何国家，在自己家中看似安全的环境中进行。”这种图像传播的便利性还可能带来新的、更广泛的受众，这一事实
that is especially alarming given the higher correlation between the practice of viewing child pornography and the commission of sex offences against children. The statement went on to explain the importance of raising awareness of the often anonymous dangers facing children when they log in online and end it with, We congratulate all those involved in Operation Cathedral. In an exclusive conversation with ZDNet News convicted Wonderland member David Hines admitted, If it wasn't for the internet, online have gone on to rape a child. Other pedophiles will start their own channel, and then they'll go looking for each other
这尤其令人震惊，因为观看儿童色情制品的行为与对儿童实施性犯罪之间存在着高度的相关性。声明接着解释了提高人们对儿童上网时面临的通常是匿名危险的认识的重要性，并以“我们祝贺所有参与‘大教堂行动’的人”结束。在与ZDNet News的独家对话中，“仙境”案定罪成员大卫·海恩斯承认：“如果不是互联网，在线可能会去强奸一个儿童。其他恋童癖者会开始他们自己的频道，然后他们会互相寻找
and read group, and the group will eventually be as big as it was with new members, with new pitches, and with all of the old pitches which are still floating around out there. His statement echoed research conducted by the National Association of Probation Officers, which concluded that most online pedophiles do not seek treatment as they don't consider themselves criminals and view their actions as victimless. Spokesperson Harry Fletcher said, We are only beginning to understand the scale of this crime. It is a major problem that their offending behaviour is not being challenged.
并阅读群组，这个群组最终会像以前一样大，有新成员，有新的照片，还有所有仍然在外面流传的旧照片。”他的声明呼应了国家缓刑官协会进行的调查，该调查得出结论称，大多数在线恋童癖者不寻求治疗，因为他们不认为自己是罪犯，并认为自己的行为是无被害人的。发言人哈里·弗莱彻说：“我们才刚刚开始了解这种犯罪的规模。他们的犯罪行为没有受到质疑，这是一个主要问题。”
Operation Cathedral faced criticism in its aftermath as only a fraction of Wonderland's 200-plus users were ever identified and arrested. Of those who were, less than half faced trial. Although the pedophile ring was found to be established in 47 countries, just 14 participated in the inquiry and were invited to the Interpol conference where the raids to take down Wonderland were planned. Some countries lacked the legal framework required expertise or political will to tackle the issue, or their law enforcement agencies were considered too corrupt to participate
“大教堂行动”在结束后受到批评，因为“仙境”200多名用户中只有极少数被识别身份并逮捕。在被捕的人中，不到一半的人面临审判。尽管这个恋童癖网络被发现成立于47个国家，但只有14个国家参与了调查，并受邀参加了国际刑警组织会议，会上策划了取缔“仙境”的突袭行动。一些国家缺乏解决该问题所需的法律框架、专业知识或政治意愿，或者其执法机构被认为过于腐败，无法参与敏感的国际调查。
in a sensitive international inquiry. According to a report released by the International Network to End Child Prostitution Pornography and Trafficking, excluded countries included Ireland, New Zealand, Israel, Japan, Spain and South Africa. Holland and Canada were initially involved but pulled out of the operation shortly before the raids were scheduled to go ahead. The Dutch police took action against a number of suspects later on, but the Canadian authorities never tackled their 14 suspects.
根据终结儿童卖淫、色情和贩运国际网络发布的一份报告，被排除在外的国家包括爱尔兰、新西兰、以色列、日本、西班牙和南非。荷兰和加拿大最初参与其中，但在突袭行动预定进行前不久退出了行动。荷兰警方后来对多名嫌疑人采取了行动，但加拿大当局从未处理过他们的14名嫌疑人。
Despite these criticisms, Operation Cathedral inspired several other global inquiries in the preceding years, including Blue Hawker, Candyman, Artis and Twin Odysseus, which resulted in the identification of thousands more online predators from across the world. In 2001, the British National Crime Squad was at the forefront of another international crackdown titled Operation Landmark, which saw the arrest of another 130 suspected pedophiles from 19 countries. As a result of that investigation, authorities were able to add another 60,000 obscene images to its database to assist in victim identification and global missing children cases.
尽管存在这些批评，“大教堂行动”在随后几年激发了其他几项全球调查，包括“蓝鹰”、“糖果人”、“阿蒂斯”和“双子奥德修斯”，这些调查锁定了来自世界各地的数千名更多的网络虐童者。2001年，英国国家犯罪局走在另一场名为“地标行动”的国际打击行动的前沿，该行动逮捕了来自19国的另外130名疑似恋童癖者。作为该调查的结果，当局在其数据库中增添了另外6万张淫秽图像，以协助识别受害者和处理全球失踪儿童案件。
In the UK, the seven convicted Wonderland members were steadily released from prison, with some serving less than half of their allotted time. Upon their release, several of the men changed their names and went on to re-offend. In 2012, former Wonderland member Gavin Seegers changed his name to Gavin Smith and was re-arrested after he was caught online discussing his fantasies of sexual abuse and torture against children. He pled guilty to nine offences of publishing obscene material and was handed a three-month suspended jail sentence.
在英国，“仙境”组织的七名被定罪成员相继获释，其中一些人的服刑时间甚至不到指定刑期的一半。刑满释放后，其中几名男子改名并再次犯罪。2012年，“仙境”前成员加文·西格斯将名字改为加文·史密斯，在网上讨论其对儿童实施性虐待和折磨的幻想时被发现，随后再次被捕。他对九项发布淫秽物品的罪名认罪，并被判处三个月缓刑。
On December 11, 2010, a staff member at Manchester's Old Trafford Library contacted police to report that a man had been witnessed viewing and uploading indecent images of minors. He had been using the library's computers near the children's book section. When the offender reappeared at the library two days later, police placed him under arrest, seizing two computers and four memory sticks. He was identified as 49-year-old Anthony Andrews of no fixed address. Analysis of the computers revealed Andrews had been interacting with a highly sophisticated global pedophile network that was under investigation by the FBI and authorities in Italy.
2010年12月11日，曼彻斯特老特拉福德图书馆的一名工作人员联系警方，报告称目击一名男子在浏览和上传未成年人淫秽图片。他一直使用图书馆靠近儿童图书区的电脑。两天后，当这名违法者再次出现在图书馆时，警方将其逮捕，查获了两台电脑和四个内存条。他被确认是49岁的安东尼·安德鲁斯，无固定居所。对电脑的分析显示，安德鲁斯一直在与一个高度复杂的全球恋童癖网络进行互动，该网络正受到联邦调查局和意大利当局的调查。
A search of the hostel where Andrews was staying uncovered a locked box that contained journals full of hint-written sexual fantasies about children. He also possessed a guide on how to groom and abuse children, plus another on how to survive prison and what to do upon release. As it turned out, Anthony Andrews was the new identity adopted by convicted child molester and former Wonderland chairman Gary Salt. In April 2006, Salt was released from prison on licence after serving just half of his 12-year sentence for sex crimes against children.
对安德鲁斯暂住的旅舍进行的搜查发现了一个上锁的箱子，里面装满了写满关于儿童的暗示性性幻想的日记。他还拥有一本关于如何引诱和虐待儿童的指南，以及一本关于如何在监狱中生存以及获释后该做什么的指南。事实证明，安东尼·安德鲁斯是已被定罪的儿童虐待者、“仙境”前主席加里·索尔特采用的新身份。2006年4月，索尔特因针对儿童的性犯罪被判处12年监禁，服刑仅一半后便获假释出狱。
He broke his conditions shortly after, buying computer magazines and receiving discs in the mail from a convicted sex offender. He was subsequently recalled back to prison, where in January 2008, prison officers raided his cell and found literature outlining sexual encounters with children, and evidence to suggest Salt was plotting a new online pedophile ring. Salt was released from prison again on April 16, 2010 and joined the Manchester Library Service the day after. By December, he had downloaded 250,000 illicit images and videos of children.
他不久后违反了假释条件，购买了计算机杂志，并收到了来自一名被定罪性犯罪者的光盘邮件。他随后被收监回狱。2008年1月，狱警搜查了他的牢房，发现了概述与儿童性接触的文学作品，以及表明索尔特正在策划新的网络恋童癖团伙的证据。索尔特于2010年4月16日再次刑满释放，并于次日加入了曼彻斯特图书馆服务中心。到12月，他已经下载了25万张非法的儿童图像和视频。
Detective Constable Barry Conway of the Greater Manchester Police stated, Salt is a convicted sex offender who has shown no desire to rehabilitate. He has some sort of perverse status among other sex offenders, and in the sickening circles in which he moves, it is something he clearly relishes. Gary Salt had admitted to 25 offensives, including making indecent images of children, possessing indecent images, attempted distribution of indecent images, possessing extreme child pornography and breaching a sexual offender's prevention order. Until it could be proven he no longer posed a risk to children, Salt was jailed indefinitely,
大曼彻斯特警察局的侦探警员巴里·康威表示，索尔特是一名已被定罪的性犯罪者，没有表现出任何改过自新的愿望。他在其他性犯罪者中有着某种变态的地位，在他所处的令人作呕的圈子里，这是他显然津津乐道的事情。加里·索尔特承认了25项罪名，包括制作儿童淫秽图片、持有淫秽图片、企图分发淫秽图片、持有极端儿童色情制品以及违反性犯罪者预防令。在能够证明他对儿童不再构成威胁之前，索尔特被无限期收监，
with sentencing Judge Peter Lakin telling him, You are clearly a committed and very active pedophile who is not willing or able to address your distorted behaviour. The National Crime Squad cropped and sanitised a portion of the 750,000 images seized from Wonderland to allow investigators to better examine them for clues to help identify and locate the victims. They scrutinised the backgrounds of the pictures for any details that could help indicate where or when they were taken, such as electrical sockets, furnishings, magazines or wallpaper.
主审法官彼得·拉金对他说：“你显然是一个坚定的、非常活跃的恋童癖者，不愿或无法纠正你扭曲的行为。”国家犯罪局对从“仙境”缴获的75万张图片中的一部分进行了裁剪和清洗，以便调查人员更好地检查它们，寻找有助于识别和定位受害者的线索。他们仔细审查了图片背景中的任何细节，这些细节可能有助于指示它们是在哪里或什么时候拍摄的，例如电源插座、陈设、杂志或壁纸。
Detective Chief Inspector Alex Wood stated, For me, the worst images were the ones showing the expression on the child's face and not necessarily what's happening to them. I can't help but think of the damage that's been done. Out of 750,000 images, the faces of 1,263 individual children have been isolated and compiled into a database, categorised by gender, age and ethnicity. Interpol has distributed this database to police forces worldwide and it is only available to view through law enforcement agencies that investigate online child sex offences.
侦探总督察亚克斯·伍德表示：“对我来说，最糟糕的画面是那些展示儿童面部表情的画面，而不一定是对他们正在发生的事情。我不禁想起已经造成的伤害。”在75万张图片中，1263名独立儿童的脸被提取并汇编成一个数据库，按性别、年龄和种族分类。国际刑警组织已将该数据库分发给世界各地的警察部队，并且只能通过调查网络儿童性犯罪的执法机构进行查看。
National Crime Squad Detective Superintendent John Stewardson believes that the work of Operation Cathedral will only be complete when authorities can identify all the nameless victims in the database. Investigators hold concerns that many of these victims are at risk of further abuse or even death. Detective Constable Barry Conway of the Greater Manchester Police stated, Every indecent image recovered tells a story of harrowing abuse and we are dedicated to identifying and bringing to justice anyone involved in such offending, whether it is
国家犯罪局侦探总督察约翰·斯蒂尔德森认为，“大教堂行动”的工作只有在当局能够识别数据库中所有无名受害者时才算完成。调查人员担心，许多这些受害者面临着再次遭受虐待甚至死亡的风险。大曼彻斯特警察局的侦探警员巴里·康威表示，恢复的每一张淫秽图片都讲述了一个令人痛心的虐待故事，我们致力于识别并把任何参与此类犯罪的人绳之以法，无论是
for the sharing of images or the abuse itself. Only 17 children featured in Wonderland's immense library have been positively identified. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
为了分享图片还是虐待本身。在“仙境”庞大的资料库中，只有17名儿童被明确识别。这一集还没有评论。点击转录文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。